en la última semana varios países
occidentales han notificado infecciones
de viruela del mono en eeuu y canadá
pasando por varios países de europeos
hasta australia pero algunos expertos
creen que es poco probable que el virus
pueda alcanzar un nivel de riesgo
pandémico similar al del cob y 19
no creo que la viruela del mono tenga
capacidad para provocar una pandemia
porque es un transmisor ineficaz al no
ser contagioso durante el periodo de
incubación sin eso la viruela delbono es
un virus para el que disponemos de
contramedidas médicas y para el que ya
hemos afrontado brotes en el pasado no
es un patógeno nuevo y no se propaga
eficazmente como el ser co2 así que
existe el peligro de intentar tomar todo
lo que sabíamos sobre el commit 19 y
aplicarlo a la viruela del mundo la
viruela del mono que antes se daba
principalmente en áfrica occidental y
central es un virus poco frecuente
similar pero más leve en comparación con
la viruela humana la propagación de la
enfermedad fuera de la región suele
estar relacionada con los viajes en la
zona los síntomas suelen ser fiebre
escalofríos sarpullido y lesiones en la
cara o los genitales
muchos de los casos de occidentales se
registran a través de las relaciones
sexuales las autoridades sanitarias
están estudiando si la enfermedad
realmente se transmite por vía sexual
sin embargo nigeria que registra unos
3.000 casos anuales no ha visto la
transmisión sexual hasta la fecha nadie
ha muerto por la reciente propagación y
las vacunas contra la viruela son
eficaces así como el desarrollado de
medicamentos antivirales todavía no se
ha determinado si el inusual aumento
actual de casos fuera de áfrica indica
un cambio en el virus o en los medios de
propagación
[Música]